[Music]
[Music]
army
[Music]
[Music]
the atom bomb
[Music]
we will arrive at yokohama at 09 30
hours
we will arrive at yokohama at 0.9 30
hours debarkation priority will be in
accordance with the debarkation schedule
[Music]
general douglas macarthur
arrived at atsugi naval aerodrome near
yokohama
on august 30th 1945
as he emerged from his aircraft
he paused at the top of the steps
stuck one hand in his hip pockets
tightened his jaws around his corn cob
pipe
and surveyed the conquered lands
[Music]
this pose was repeated several times
from different angles
so that all the press photographers
could get a decent shot
democracy was to be instilled in the
japanese people
as though they had never heard of it
[Music]
our problems in the brain inside of the
japanese head
these brains like our brains can do good
things
or bad things
all depending on the kind of ideas
that are put inside
[Music]
kabuki plays featuring loyal samurai
were banned or heavily censored
as were books and films about the
bombings of hiroshima and nagasaki
satirical cartoons of macarthur and
mention of occupation censorship
were strictly forbidden
[Music]
the commission finds you guilty as
charged and sentences you to death by
hanging
yamashita himself thanked the commission
for the fairness of his trial
[Music]
prime minister at the time of the war in
the pacific general tojo
remarked during his trial
none of those japanese would dare act
against the emperor's will
the cross-examination was immediately
cut short
and a week later tojo dutifully stated
that the emperor had always loved and
wanted peace
general hideki tojo who assumed official
responsibility for the conduct of the
war and did everything possible to
exonerate his emperor
macarthur would later remark to the u.s
senate that in terms of modern
civilization
the japanese were like a 12 year old boy
[Music]
[Music]
you are interested in the unknown the
mysterious the unexplainable
that is why you are here
when the war was over
bank loan books had deteriorated
the assets the banks held were mainly
war bonds and loans to destroyed
industries
as such
the whole banking sector was virtually
bankrupt
this problem was easily solved by the
bank of japan
all it had to do was buy the banking
sector's bad papers with newly created
reserves
giving them good money for assets which
were often worthless
the first two post-war central bank
governors were nominated by the u.s
occupation
ekichi iraqi was appointed the first
post-war governor of the bank of japan
but soon after taking up this post
he was indicted by war crimes
prosecutors
and had to resign
then in 1951
after a general amnesty on suspected war
criminals filling public offices
he was made ambassador to the united
states
on returning from his post as ambassador
in 1954
iraqi was again made governor of the
central bank
after the 1951 amnesty for war criminals
much of the japanese wartime bureaucracy
was returned to their wartime positions
this included wartime politicians
and most home ministry bureaucrats who
had been in charge of the thought police
a number of which moved to the education
ministry
japan is the key to the fate of the far
east
once again for the second time in the
march of modern history
those words have urgent reality
in order to avert the kind of rural
unrest that was helping the communists
in china
the americans initiated the
redistribution of land from big
landowners to their tenants
the capitalist elite in japan
known as the zaibatsu
were purged as supporters of a criminal
war
and prohibited from further business
activity
basically that the fascist uh policies
of the thirties that the the reformed
fascist bureaucrats could not implement
during the war even yes the u.s
occupation managed to complete like the
land reform and right these diverse
policies yeah it's a very funny
encounter of
japanese wartime fascists and
american
new dealers
[Music]
the diet
home of japan's senate and house of
representatives
in japan fanatic students and leftist
groups rioted for days on end seeking to
block the mutual defense treaty with
america
the socialist deputies staged a riot in
the diet itself
the police in restoring order
also evicted the socialists
[Music]
the speaker was carried to the platform
and called to order the session that
approved the treaty
in 1957
the former class a war crime suspect
kishi nobusuke
became prime minister of japan
he had been general together's minister
of commerce and industry during the war
where his responsibilities had ranged
from munitions to slave labor
while hitler's um
wartime
war minister war economy minister was in
berlin spandau prison yes
his japanese wartime colleague was prime
minister right of the country
although kishi became a defender of
democracy after the war
before and during the war he had
described himself as a national
socialist
with money from crime syndicates
industrial corporations and cia funds
he she built the liberal democratic
party
into a powerful political machine
in japan
many of the most important post-war
economic and political leaders
came from an elite group of wartime
bureaucrats
the very same people who had pushed
japan into the war
the liberal democratic party
stayed in power for almost 40 years
[Music]
welcome home in japanese
to these american soldiers
after a tour of duty in korea they are
returning to their base in japan where
once a short time before they were
stationed as occupation troops
and how do they return
how are they received by the people
whose land they occupy
not as overlords
not as antagonists
not as men who are distrusted and feared
and presented but as friends
[Music]
[Music]
in tokyo's central tioda board the
ministry of finance had its headquarters
from here the ministry controlled most
aspects of economic life in japan
the ministry of finance was
the most powerful ministry and the bank
of japan had to report to the ministry
of finance
ministry of finance officials elicited
deep and hushed exclamations of awe and
respect
and former ministry bureaucrats obtained
influential posts as heads of private
and public institutions
[Music]
but in one area the ministry did not
have actual control
and that was the quantity of credit
creation and its allocation
which was decided by the japanese
central bank
the bank of japan
they told the ministry finance and the
public and the journalists
we run monetary policy through interest
rates
and they let the ministry of finance
reign
in their interest rate policies
but the rule
was done through not interest rates
which is the price of money it was done
through the quantity of money
[Music]
it worked this way it's called window
guidance the bank of japan just told the
banks how much they were going to lend
they will have to lend in the coming
quarter and who which sector of the
economy to lend to
credit allocation credit control the
bank of japan gave quarterly
instructions to individual banks on the
value of loans and which industrial
sectors they should be allocated to
all loans were broken down in sectors
and sub-sectors
and large-scale borrowers had to be
listed by name
[Music]
the bank of japan could decide which
project should be encouraged
and which should be discouraged
by dictating to whom and for what banks
could issue loans
[Music]
this was the war economy system
adapted to the production of consumer
goods
[Music]
the 95 million people of japan
now enjoy a national income second only
to the united states
and the more prosperous nations of
western europe
it's not a good system for capitalists
you know shareholders
but for the population it created a lot
of wealth
very
even income and wealth distribution very
high growth and very rapidly raised
quality of life and standards
[Music]
in 1959 alone the economy expanded by 17
percent
but a result of the war economy system
was that entire industrial sectors would
compete not for profit
but for market share
companies would fight until bankruptcy
to gain market share
this phenomenon was soon recognized and
called excess competition
the solution was the creation of
explicit or implicit cartels
in the banking sector window guidance
acted as the cartel control mechanism
because the bank of japan could dictate
the number and value of loans that banks
issued
as a result
bank rankings never changed during the
post-war era
except after mergers
according to one banker
if it were not for window guidance
we would compete until harakiri
the u.s current account deficit surges
to its highest level in nine years the
size of the increase took many economies
by surprise
while cartels controlled competition
within japan
there were no such limits when it came
to international markets
japanese corporations soon became
dominant in many markets in the world
[Music]
in america
formal congressional hearings were held
under the title
japanese productivity lessons for
america
[Music]
leading economic theories indicate that
only free markets can lead to success
but japan rose within decades to become
the second largest economy in the world
without relying only on the invisible
hand of free markets
japan's post-war economy was a fully
mobilized war economy
with production shifted from weapons
to consumer goods
[Music]
[Music]
since the bank of japan presented itself
as a champion of free markets
window guidance was an embarrassment
official publications either failed to
mention it
or downplayed its role by calling the
credit controls
voluntary
whenever the ministry of finance would
inquire about the bank of japan's credit
creation and allocation policy
bank of japan staff would engage in
complex discussions full of technical
jargon
to make the process appear impenetrable
to non-experts
in november 1965
the first batch of japanese government
bonds came onto the market
from now on when politicians wanted to
spend more
they would no longer put pressure on the
bank of japan
but instead exerted on the ministry of
finance
so the ministry would ultimately preside
over an ever increasing national debt
mountain
[Music]
the 1980s was an era of financial
deregulation in the industrialized world
most industrialized countries lifted
their restrictions on the movement of
capital
in japan
tadashi sasaki
a former governor of the bank of japan
called for a five-year plan for the
transformation and liberalization of the
japanese economy
[Music]
then in 1986
the advisory group on economic
restructuring
headed by the former bank of japan
governor
hiruo maikawa
proposed a 10-year economic reform plan
designed to make the living standards of
japanese more comparable to those
enjoyed in the west
the proposal stated that
the time has now come for japan to make
a historical transformation
in its traditional policies on economic
management and the nation's lifestyle
there can be no further development for
japan
without this transformation
[Music]
the report
read like a wish list by u.s trade
negotiators
it started with calls for administrative
reform and the abolition of bureaucratic
powers
the goal was the transformation of the
entire body politic
the abolition of the war economy system
and the introduction of a u.s style free
market economy
those members of the advisory group who
uttered dissent
were relieved of their duties
[Music]
reports in the press were highly
critical
observers recognized the radical nature
of the plan
seemed far too ambitious
it was calling for a wholesale
revolution
of all parts of the japanese economic
political and social system
[Music]
although the report was clear about what
was wanted
it was embarrassingly silent about how
these goals would be achieved
the only clue hidden in the report was
in the implementation of these
recommendations
fiscal and monetary policy have a
significant part to play
[Music]
the bank of japan has always been on the
record arguing that this typical
japanese system that we're so familiar
with
should be scrapped it just should be
entirely scrapped and u.s style
capitalism should be introduced now
whether you agree with that or not is an
entirely separate question but the bank
of japan certainly thinks it should be
scrapped and
now the next question is how do you do
that well the ministry of finance has
been legally in control for most of the
post-war era we've got entrenched
bureaucratic structures uh politicians
and all these cartels and so on
that was the old system well history
teaches the system changes only
fundamentally if there's a crisis
[Music]
the commission proposed that monetary
policy
should be used to promote a historic
crisis
[Music]
sufficiently large to overcome the
vested interests of the ministry of
finance
politicians
and corporate japan
[Music]
every system has groups that benefit
from it and hence have no desire to
change it
there is probably no country in the
world that has changed its economic
social and political system in a
significant way without a crisis
[Music]
it is the crisis
that convinces citizens and interest
groups
of the need for change
well then how can you achieve this
um
well you need a crisis
the best way to create it is to have a
bubble because that's how nobody stops
you
[Music]
the bank of japan began to significantly
increase window guidance loan quotas
average yearly loan growth quotas were
close to 15
in the late 1980s
[Music]
one city banker would later remark
during the bubble we wanted a certain
amount of loan increases
but the bank of japan wanted us to use
more
[Music]
[Music]
the credit boom caused not only a boom
in real estate
but also in the stock market
between 1985 and 1989
stocks rose 240 percent
and land prices
245 percent
[Music]
by the end of the 80s
the value of the garden surrounding the
imperial palace in central tokyo
was worth as much as the entire state of
california
[Music]
although japan is only 1 26 the size of
the united states
its land was valued at four times that
of the united states
[Music]
the market value of a single one of
tokyo's 23 districts
the central chiyoda ward
exceeded the value of the whole of
canada
economists who are trained to believe in
market outcomes
tried to justify the high land prices
some thought land scarcity was the
reason
shiny new corporate headquarters rose in
tokyo's posh business districts
[Music]
the labor market boomed so much
that there was a genuine fear of a
serious labor shortage
companies started to invite final year
university students on expensive trips
to holiday resorts
to entice them to sign up
[Music]
the politicians loved it the ministry of
finance loved it where the boom tax
revenues going up the companies loved it
everything was wonderful in the bubble
era
[Music]
with asset and stock prices rising
inexorably
even traditional manufacturers could not
resist the temptation to try their hand
at playing the markets
soon they expanded their finance and
treasury divisions
to handle the speculation themselves
these company hedge funds known as zytec
use borrowed money to engage in property
and share speculation
the frenzy reached such proportions
that many leading manufacturers
such as the car maker nissan
made more money through speculative
investments
than through manufacturing cars
[Music]
literally thousands of articles were
written on the new japanese miracle
economy
a common explanation by economists
was that high and rising productivity
explained the impressive performance of
japan's economy
books on japanese management techniques
became international best sellers
western businessmen
read 17th century tracts on samurai
strategies
in reality
japan's stellar performance in the 1980s
had little to do with management
techniques
instead of being used to limit and
direct credit
window guidance was used to create a
giant bubble
i conducted research actually
interviewing the bank of japan officers
and bankers
on both sides on you know on tape the
result was the bank of japan did
continue its informal guidance in fact
it was the bank of japan that forced the
banks to increase their lending so much
the bank of japan
knew that the only way for banks to
fulfill their loan quotas
was for them to expand non-productive
lending
in the words of one banker
if there is no demand for credit from
low-risk borrowers
and we want to use up the quota
the risk gets worse
another banker is quoted as saying that
a side effect of the window guidance
rule of loan increases
was that the banks increased lending
even when there was no loan demand
like all bubbles
the japanese bubble was simply fueled by
the rapid creation of new money by the
banking system
between 1986 and 1989
toshihiko fukui was the head of the
banking department at the bank of japan
this was the department that was
responsible for the window guidance
quotas
when fukui was asked by a journalist
borrowing is expanding fast
don't you have any intention of closing
the tap on bank loans
he replied
because the consistent policy of
monetary easing continues
quantity control of bank loans would
imply a self-contradiction
therefore we do not intend to implement
quantitative tightening
with structural adjustment of the
economy going on for quite a long period
the international imbalances are being
addressed
the monetary policy supports this
thus we have the responsibility to
continue the monetary easing policy
as long as possible
therefore it is natural for bank loans
to expand
why were the banks lending so much well
they were lending so much because they
were forced to do so by the orders of
the bank of japan
normally
banks choose clients from among a large
number of loan applicants
turning down a significant percentage
but from 1987 onwards the tables had
turned
it was the bankers who were aggressively
pursuing potential customers
anecdotes abound about how the banks
were soliciting loans at bargain
interest rates
pursuing clients like street peddlers
bankers made increasingly exaggerated
assessments of land value
so that the actual ratio of land value
to loan
often jumped to 300 or more
to the public this was a strange
phenomenon
people soon dubbed it
excess money
only economists analysts and those
working in the financial markets or for
real estate firms knew better
they dismissed such simplistic analysis
land prices were going up due to far
more complicated reasons than just
excess money they claimed
ordinary people simply did not
understand the intricacies of advanced
financial technology
when a country creates too much money
some of that money spills out abroad in
the form of investments
in the 1980s
japanese capital flows multiplied from a
net inflow of more than two billion
dollars in 1980
to an outflow of 132 billion dollars in
1986
assets including art objects and other
valuables all over the world
became targets for japanese buyers
there were high profile purchases such
as the rockefeller center columbia
pictures
and pebble beach golf course
japanese money bought a staggering 75
percent of all united states treasury
bonds auctioned off in 1986
[Music]
but it is not easy for a country to just
print money and then go on a shopping
spree around the world
japan was able to do this
because the markets did not devalue its
currency
the value of individual currencies
is set by currency dealers
if the traditional indicators that the
currency dealers watch do not pick up
the excess money creation in the country
concerned
then creating large amounts of money and
trying to exchange it for foreign
currency
can work
japan had pulled off the same trick that
the united states had used in the 1950s
and 1960s
when u.s banks excessively created
dollars
corporate america used this hot money to
buy up european corporations
while the united states had the cover of
the dollar gold standard
japan's cover was a significant trade
surplus
[Music]
[Music]
an early warning indicator the build-up
of systemic risk in the banking system
is a ratio of loans for non-gdp-based
transactions
to total loans
this ratio increases significantly in
most countries that are subsequently
struck by a banking crisis
it was this same process
that fueled the mortgage lending and
house price booms in the united states
and the united kingdom
in the 1980s and the 2000s
the same process also created the golden
20s
in the 1920s united states banks lent
with stocks as collateral
the principle remains the same
as each bank took the stock price as a
given
it created new money
with more money in the stock market
stock prices had to rise
[Music]
each bank thought it was safe accepting
a certain percentage of the value of the
stock as collateral
but the actions of all banks together
drove up the overall market
in japan
total private sector land wealth
rose from 14.2 trillion yen in 1969
[Music]
to 2000 trillion yen in 1989
at his first press conference was the
26th governor of the bank of japan in
1989
yasushi miano said that
since the previous policy of monetary
easing had caused the land price rise
problems
real estate related lending would now be
restricted
he looked around looked at the bubble
as the prices rising you know the gap
between rich and poor is getting bigger
let's stop it
his name was mr mieno
and he was a hero in the press because
he
fought against this silly monarchy
policy
well the fact was he was deputy governor
during the bubble era and he was in
charge of creating the bubble
[Music]
all of a sudden land and asset prices
stopped rising
in 1990 alone the stock market dropped
by 32 percent
[Music]
then in july 1991 window guidance was
abolished
this took the window guidance officers
at the bank of japan themselves by
surprise
bankers were left almost helpless
they complained that they did not know
how to make their lending plans anymore
in the past
when a certain branch had said they
would like to lend more
they would respond that the window
guidance quota had been used up
now they couldn't do that anymore
as banks began to realize that the
majority of the 99 trillion yen in
bubble loans were likely to turn sour
they became so fearful that they not
only stopped lending to speculators
but also restricted loans to everyone
else
well it's a bleak christmas ahead for
japan the stock market on monday sinking
to its lowest close in over two years
last week's collapse of one of japan's
biggest food traders was the ninth time
this year that enlisted company went
under
more than 5 million japanese lost their
jobs
and did not find employment elsewhere
suicide became the leading cause of
death for men between the ages of 20 and
44.
[Music]
so
[Music]
between 1990 and 2003
two hundred and twelve thousand
companies went bankrupt
in the same period the stock market
dropped by eighty percent
land prices in the major cities fell by
up to 84 percent
some economists seemed relieved
the downturn was evidence that japan's
economic system was not so successful
after all
meanwhile
the governor of the bank of japan
yasushi mieno
said that
thanks to this recession
everyone is becoming conscious of the
need to implement economic
transformation
the ministry of finance believing that
interest rates were the main policy tool
put pressure on the bank of japan to
lower interest rates
until the official rate reached 0.1
percent
most economists predicted an economic
recovery
but despite frequent assertions in the
financial press and by central banks
that lower interest rates will stimulate
growth
and higher interest rates will slow
growth
there is no empirical evidence for this
relationship
[Music]
japanese and american businessmen are
meeting here with a plea from japan's
companies for a lower yen
only six percent of japanese exporters
can make profits with the dollar at less
than a hundred yen on average they need
the american currency to rise above 117
yen to break even
[Music]
the ministry of finance asked the bank
of japan to sell large amounts of yen
and buy u.s dollars
so that the exchange rate of the yen
would fall
and exports would pick up
we all know that two of them the
ministry of finance moth in japan and
the bank of japan they just don't get
along well
and what has been happening also again
this month is that the bank of japan has
been sterilizing its own intervention
well to be precise the intervention
ordered by the ministry of finance the
ministry of finance tells the bank of
japan to go out and buy well we had a
figure roughly 20 billion worth of u.s
treasuries
but the bank of japan is sterilizing
this which means it is basically taking
the money from the economy to fund this
purchase most researchers agree
sterilized forex intervention doesn't
work the boj is again sterilizing that's
why it doesn't work that's why the yen
has remained strong
[Music]
a central bank can withdraw money from
the economy by selling its assets
just as it can inject money into the
economy by buying assets
when central banks buy and sell assets
they increase or decrease the amount of
money circulating in the economy
[Music]
officials at the bank of japan ignored
this
and instead claimed that
this structural transformation or reform
may produce deflationary forces in the
short run
but will generate a much more efficient
economy after a while
independent observers suggested that
domestic demand had to be boosted by
government spending
and then loan demand would also rise
for a decade the government followed
their advice
boosting government debt to historic
levels
between 1992 and 2002
10 stimulation packages worth 146
trillion yen were issued
mr richard werner is chief economist at
jardine fleming securities in tokyo he
joins us now to share his views on where
the japanese economy is heading mr
vernon good evening to you thank you for
joining us the government was spending
with the right hand putting money into
the economy but the fundraising was done
through the bond market and therefore it
took the same money out of the economy
with a left hand there was no increase
in total purchasing pound that's why the
government spending couldn't have an
impact
by 2011
japan's government debt would reach 230
percent of gdp
the highest in the world
the ministry of finance was running out
of
options observers began to blame the
ministry for the recession
and started to listen to the voices that
argued that the recession was due to
japan's economic system
but how difficult would it have been to
solve the problems of bad debt in the
banking sector and deflation
it turns out that this would not have
been so difficult after all
financial system always looks like
catch-22 there's no loan growth so
there's no economic growth so there's no
loan growth so there's no economic
growth well
there is one thing that can break
through that this uh circular argument
that's the central bank the job of the
central bank in this situation is to
print money
what we need now is
more radical measures and there are some
painful ones but they're also painless
ones the central bank could for example
just buy all bad debts at face value
japan would have the strongest banks in
the world
to bail out the banking sector a central
bank can buy up the bank's bad financial
assets with newly created money
giving them face value for assets which
are often worth significantly less
[Music]
this is what the bank of japan did after
the war
alternatively money could be transferred
to the banks by helping them make
sizeable profits
one way this can be achieved is for the
central bank to corner a market
in effect creating a mini bubble in a
certain market in which banks invest
heavily
providing large profits for them
this turns out to be a relatively common
technique by central banks to help their
banking systems
[Music]
other proposals include measures to
introduce zero-risk borrowers to banks
or introducing accounting changes that
help their balance sheets
[Music]
in japan
the authorities and the bank of japan
argued as did the western powers almost
two decades later
that the taxpayer should foot the bill
in march
last year
as you may remember
government injected a large amount of
money
into some 15 major
japanese financial institutions and we
were one of them yeah
that helped us
right of bad debts
and also to beef up our capital base
so that we would be prepared to lend
tax money has been used to recapitalize
banks
however there is no evidence that
taxpayers have been responsible for the
bank's problems
therefore such policies have likely
created a moral hazard
[Music]
the money supply is determined by the
net increase in money creation by banks
and the central bank
if moral hazard dictates that the
banking sector should not be bailed out
deflation and recession can still be
avoided by the central bank
to do this the central bank can increase
the money supply
a central bank can increase the amount
of money in an economy at any time
without limit
by simply buying assets from the private
sector
and paying with newly created credit
[Music]
the bank of japan could for instance
have bought real estate and converted it
into public parks
and there is an opportunity here to
solve three problems in one stroke the
economy needs money creation the banks
need to get rid of their bad debt and
the real estate sector needs some
transactions well what he can do is just
have the central bank print money
buy the land from the banks
turn it into parks
and actually you solve another problem
quality of life in japan
even if the bank of japan had later sold
these parks at a fraction of the cost
it would still have made money
because it costs a central bank nothing
to create the money in the first place
another option for injecting money into
the economy is quantitative easing
despite having all these options
available
the bank of japan at every stage refused
to implement policies that would have
resolved the crises
when i was at the bank of japan 9293 as
a visiting researcher
i was convinced that this recession was
going to get really bad so any bank of
japan guy who i could get to talk to me
i would ask well
why aren't you printing more money i
noticed they were not printing enough
money
and i met one
guy who was quite open about then he
said richard yeah sure we could have put
pretty more money we could have created
a recovery but then nothing would have
changed japan's economic structure would
not have changed
now that time i still wasn't ready to
believe that the bank of japan was
seriously prolonging the recession on
purpose in order to get structural
changes that just seemed a bit too wild
finance minister masojiro shiokawa has
turned to the bank of japan asking it to
help stop deflation or fight deflation
at least the bank of japan consistently
defied calls by the government finance
minister and prime minister to create
more money to stimulate the economy
and end the long recession
[Music]
at times the bank of japan even actively
reduced the amount of money circulating
in the economy
which worsened the recession
[Music]
the bank of japan's arguments always
came to the same conclusion
namely that the blame lay with japan's
economic structure
central bank staff even argued that
significant monetary easing could cause
harm
by inducing a further delay in the
progress of structural adjustment
[Music]
the early post-war japanese leaders
knew that they were running a war
economy
but they chose not to talk for political
reasons
the cold war propaganda message was that
post-war japan had adopted a us-style
political and economic system
unwilling to tell the truth
the early post-war leaders took their
intimate knowledge about the origins of
japan's miracle economy
with them to their grave
a generation of bureaucrats and
politicians reigned in the 1980s and
1990s who did not understand the true
character and purpose of their own
country's economy
[Music]
a whole generation of japan's economists
had been sent to the united states
to receive phds and mbas in u.s style
economics
since neoclassical economics assumes
that there is only one type of economic
system
namely unmitigated free markets where
shareholders and central bankers ruled
supreme
many japanese economists
quickly came to regurgitate the
arguments of u.s economists
[Music]
the u.s and japan closed two days of
insurance talks on tuesday primary
sector deregulation
is needed to overcome
the entrenched interests
of large insurance companies life and
non-life
and the ministry of finance bureaucracy
they need to reach an agreement before
december the 15th after that date the us
has threatened to impose trade sanctions
will key move analysts are expecting the
securitization of real estate will the
package be enough for more we are
talking to richard werner to have uh
meaningful uh securitization we need
deregulation and that's already the
answer to your question
to get deregulation you have to reduce
the power of the ministry of finance and
obviously the ministry was resisting
that
in the 1980s
persons who could introduce themselves
with a business card from the renowned
finance ministry
elicited deep and hushed exclamations of
awe and respect
but by the mid-1990s
attitudes had changed
there now seemed little doubt to most
observers that the ministry of finance
had caused the recession
[Music]
the frequent demonstrations were held
outside the ministry's doors
by citizens disgusted by the
bureaucrat's actions
in early 1998 public prosecutors for the
first time
raided the most powerful of japan's
ministries
both banks and their regulators were
heavily criticized for their actions
scandals highlighted some of the
informal links that existed between
ministry of finance officials and
bankers
many bank staff and even some ministry
officials were arrested and imprisoned
and several committed suicide
as central banker masaki shirakawa had
explained
it is not easy to change the
institutional framework and promote
structural reform
since it necessarily involves the vested
interests of all the related individual
economic agents
while yutaka yamaguchi
a deputy governor of the bank of japan
had said that
the bank of japan had faced the big
dilemma that monetary easing would
produce the mitigation of immediate
risks
which in turn would result in a delaying
of adopting ultimate solutions
from the mid-1990s onwards
the government began to dismantle much
of the power structure of the ministry
of finance
the bank of japan on the other hand
saw its influence grow significantly
you have written just recently there's
no doubt in your mind the central bank
the bank of japan will be cut loose from
the ministry of finance and become
pretty much independent putting it on a
footing with other central banks
briefly why are you so sure
basically the minister of finance which
had been
controlling
legally at least the bank of japan i
mean that's what the law says
has lost all credibility the minister of
finance is being blamed for the creation
of the bubble for the long recession and
for many other problems which had which
had we had recently in japan whereas the
bank of japan has been
out of the spotlight of public criticism
and it's using that now to say well the
moff has been bad we need independence
now richard thanks very much i have been
speaking to richard werner chief
economist at jardine fleming securities
in tokyo
[Music]
soon after his retirement from the
position of governor of the bank of
japan in 1994
miyano embarked on a campaign
giving speeches to various associations
and interest groups
he lobbied for a change in the bank of
japan law
his line of argument
was to subtly suggest that the ministry
of finance had pushed the bank of japan
into the wrong policies
to avoid such problems in the future
the bank of japan needed to be given
full legal independence
according to mieno
making central banks independent
reflected the human wisdom that had been
nurtured by history
in 1998
monetary policy was put into the hands
of the newly independent bank of japan
so you're saying that politicians as
well as economists should be putting
more pressure towards the bank of japan
in order to create more money but a lot
of critics are going to say that that is
intervening into the central bank's
independence what do you make of that um
i think i think that's exactly right
that is intervening in the central banks
in independence and that's exactly what
we need
the numerous scandals that followed the
bursting of the bubble also brought down
the 1955 system of one-party rule
by the liberal democratic party
in the old system politicians did not
compete by proposing different policies
policy was made by the bureaucrats
and politicians merely focused on
appeasing local constituencies
with public works projects
in october 1997 for the first time in
post-war history
all policy initiatives to stimulate the
economy originated from politicians
not bureaucrats
then in early 2001
a new type of politician was swept to
power
japanese government bonds staged their
biggest rally this month as junichiro
koizumi emerged as the hot favorite to
become the country's next prime minister
junichiro koizumi became prime minister
in terms of his popularity and his
policies he is often compared to
margaret thatcher and ronald reagan
his message was simple
no recovery without structural reform
[Music]
at the geneva summit in july 2001 he
said
some say recovery comes first
without reforms
but if the economy recovers the will to
reform will disappear
therefore after the elections
i will continue with the plan of no
growth without structural reform
during 2001 the message of no economic
growth without structural reform had
been broadcast on an almost daily basis
on the nation's tv screens
[Music]
now everyone believes
we need structural changes we need to
scrap japanese style capitalism to get a
recovery why it seems we tried all the
policies it seems we've tried everything
nothing works so the system itself the
japanese style economic system must be
to blame so we better get rid of it
[Music]
japan was shifting its economic system
to a u.s style market economy
and that also meant that the center of
the economy was being moved from banks
to stock markets
to entice depositors to pull their money
out of banks and into the risky stock
market
reformers withdrew the guarantee on all
bank deposits
while creating tax incentives for stock
investments
as u.s style shareholder capitalism
spread
unemployment rose significantly
income and wealth disparities rose
as did suicides and incidents of violent
crime
then in 2002
the bank of japan strengthened its
efforts to worsen bank balance sheets
and force banks to foreclose on their
borrowers
until then hakuwa yanagasawa minister
for financial services had resisted the
bank of japan-inspired proposal to
inject tax money into banks
effectively nationalizing them taking
over their management and using this
power to call in loans from companies
thus triggering many bankruptcies of
large firms
[Music]
mr yanigasawa was duly sacked by the
prime minister and replaced with hezo
takanaka
takanaka was a supporter of the bank of
japan's plan to increase foreclosures of
borrowers
minister takanaka was trying to
implement a policy to actually
dramatically weaken the balance sheets
of the banks in order to give him a free
hand and allow him to nationalize them
takanaka appointed a task force to
oversee the banking policies
which included two former bank of japan
staff
one of them takeshi kimura
immediately demanded that accounting
changes be implemented which would
worsen bank balance sheets and render
nationalization unavoidable
takuru morinaga a well-known economist
in tokyo
argued forcefully that the bank of japan
inspired proposal by takanaka would not
have many indigenous beneficiaries
but instead would mainly benefit us
vulture funds specializing in the
purchase of distressed assets
these vulture funds had faced the
difficulty that despite over 200 000
bankruptcies
few firms sufficiently large for the
vulture funds to be interested
were bankrupted
when kimuras and fukui's support for the
bankruptcy plan was voiced
the former operated a private company
that advised on the securitization of
distressed assets
and the latter was an advisor of the
wall street investment firm goldman
sachs
one of the largest operators of vulture
funds in the world
mr fukui also his mentor mr mino and and
his mentor mr maikawa and you've guessed
it these are some of the princes of the
yen that the book is all about they have
said on the record in the 80s and also
throughout the 90s what is the goal of
monetary policy it is to change the
economic structure now how do you do
that well you need a crisis and that's
really what they've done they've raised
the crisis which changed the economy
we're just out of time
thank you so much
the department responsible for the
window guidance quotas of the bank of
japan
was called the banking department and
who was in charge of this the man the
head of this banking department inside
the bank of japan during the bubble from
86 to 89 was toshihiko fukui mr fukui
the current governor of the bank of
japan he's the man who created the
bubble
when fukui had become governor of the
bank of japan
he would say
while destroying the high growth model
i am building a model that suits the new
era
they have succeeded on all counts
if you look at the list of their of
their goals and you know it was more
than a wish list it's more or less a
plan that they mapped out
they wanted to achieve they've reached
all those goals destroy the minister
finance
break it up get an independent financial
supervisory agency
reach independence for the bank of japan
itself by changing the bank of japan law
and
engineer deep structural changes in the
economy um by shifting from
manufacturing to services opening up
deregulating liberating liberalizing
privatizing the whole lot
in the 1920s japan's economy in many
ways resembled today's us economy
with fierce competition
aggressive hiring and firing
takeover battles between large
corporations
few bureaucratic controls
strong shareholders that demanded high
dividends
and corporate funding from the markets
not banks
yet throughout the post-war era
japan's economy had been the opposite
highly regulated with cartel's limiting
competition
bank financing and cross shareholdings
reducing shareholder power
no takeovers and a frozen labor market
with lifetime employment and seniority
pay
it was claimed that to end the recession
and improve performance
japan must shift from welfare capitalism
back to shareholder capitalism
yet it remains unclear why a country
that had run a consistent and
significant balance of trade surplus
would need to change its economic system
to become more competitive
[Music]
japan was not the only high-performance
economy in asia that in the 1990s found
itself in the deepest recession since
the great depression
[Music]
in 1997
the currencies of the southeast asian
tiger economies could not maintain a
fixed exchange rate with the u.s dollar
they collapsed by between 60 and 80
percent within a year
[Music]
the causes for this crash went as far
back as 1993
in that year the asian tiger economies
south korea thailand and indonesia
implemented a policy of aggressive
deregulation of the capital account
and the establishment of international
banking facilities
which enabled the corporate and banking
sectors to borrow liberally from abroad
the first time in the post-war era that
borrowers could do so
[Music]
in reality there was no need for the
asian tiger economies to borrow money
from abroad
all the money necessary for domestic
investment could be created at home
indeed the pressure to liberalize
capital flows came from outside
since the early 1990s the imf the world
trade organization and the us treasury
had been lobbying these countries to
allow domestic firms to borrow from
abroad
they argued that neoclassical economics
had proven that free markets and free
capital movement
increased economic growth
once the capital accounts had been
deregulated
the central banks set about creating
irresistible incentives for domestic
firms to borrow from abroad
by making it more expensive to borrow in
their own domestic currencies than it
was to borrow in u.s dollars
domestic local interest rates were high
or higher than the u.s dollar interest
rate
okay
and the exchange rate uh
was
virtually fixed
it was the government and the central
bank that said we will maintain the
exchange rate that's right that's right
central banks of uh of thailand and
other east asian countries resisted uh
exchange rate adjustment
uh
and they they
tried to send the signal that they would
protect the exchange rate
the central banks emphasized in their
public statements
that they would maintain fixed exchange
rates with the us dollar
so that borrowers did not have to worry
about paying back more in their domestic
currencies
than they had originally borrowed
when i went to thailand i was actually
on an adb mission as an outside
consultant
i went straight to the bank of thailand
and asked them were there any informal
credit
uh guidance schemes
and they were surprised that i asked
this question because of my study of
japan i thought
perhaps there's something similar and
they told me it was a young staff who
perhaps wasn't aware of the politics
involved he said yeah yeah we have this
credit planning scheme
banks were ordered to increase lending
but they were faced with less loan
demand from the productive sectors of
the economy
because these firms had been given
incentives to borrow from abroad instead
they therefore had to resort to
increasing their lending to higher risk
borrowers
[Music]
imports began to shrink
because the central banks had agreed to
peg their currencies to the us dollar
the economies became less competitive
but their current account balance was
maintained due to the foreign issued
loans
which counters exports in the balance of
payment statistics
when speculators began to sell the thai
baht the korean one
and the indonesian rupee
the respective central banks responded
with futile attempts to maintain the peg
until they had squandered virtually all
of their foreign exchange reserves
this gave foreign lenders ample
opportunity to withdraw their money at
the overvalued exchange rates
the central banks knew that if the
countries ran out of foreign exchange
reserves
they would have to call in the imf to
avoid default
and once the imf came in
the central banks knew what this
washington-based institution would
demand
for its demands in such cases had been
the same for the previous three decades
the central banks would be made
independent
on the 16th of july the thai finance
minister took a plane to tokyo
to ask japan for a bailout
at the time
japan had 213 billion us dollars in
foreign exchange reserves
more than the total resources of the imf
they were willing to help
but washington stopped japan's
initiative
any solution to the emerging asian
crisis
had to come from washington via the imf
after two months of speculative attacks
the thai government floated the bot
well the international monetary fund
today has promised almost 120 billion
dollars to the embattled economies of
thailand indonesia and south korea
immediately after arrival in the
crisis-stricken countries
the imf teams set up offices inside the
central banks
from where they dictated what amounted
to terms of surrender
the imf demanded a string of policies
including curbs on central bank and bank
credit creation
major legal changes and sharp rises in
interest rates
as interest rates rose
high-risk borrowers began to default on
their loans
burdened with large amounts of bad debts
the banking systems of thailand korea
and indonesia were virtually bankrupt
even otherwise healthy firms started to
suffer from the widening credit crunch
corporate bankruptcies soared
unemployment rose to the highest level
since the 1930s
the role of the fund in coming to the
rescue of alienation has been fiercely
debated some have even accused the imf
of actually making asia's economic
crisis worse
even if they have to subvert our economy
they will do so just to prove that they
are right the imf has not been very
helpful
the imf knew well what the consequences
of its policies would be
in the korean case
they even had detailed but undisclosed
studies prepared that had calculated
just how many korean companies would go
bankrupt
if interest rates were to rise by five
percentage points
the imf's first agreement with korea
demanded a rise of exactly
five percentage points in interest rates
the imf policies uh are clearly not
aimed at creating economic recoveries in
the asian countries uh they pursue quite
a different agenda and that is to change
the economic social and political
systems in those countries in fact the
imf deals prevent
um the country's concerns like korea
thailand
to reflate interesting you're saying
it's making the crisis worse and you're
suggesting that the imf has a hidden
agenda well i mean it's not very hidden
this agenda because the imf quite
clearly demands
that the asian countries concern have to
change the laws
so that foreign interests can buy
anything from banks to land
and in fact the banking systems
can only be recapitalized according to
the imf deals by using foreign money
which is not necessary at all because as
long as these countries have central
banks
they could just print money and
recapitalize the banking systems you
don't need foreign money for that
so the agenda is clearly to crack open
asia
for foreign interests
the imf demanded that troubled banks
would not be bailed out
but instead closed down and sold off
cheaply as distressed assets
often to large u.s investment banks
one positive coming out of thailand is
that they'll be auctioning off
some major assets from 56 finance
companies in your view should um
some of the owners from the 56 finance
companies be allowed to buy back their
assets
in most cases
the imf dictated letters of intent
explicitly stated that the banks had to
be sold to foreign investors
and let me emphasize in that respect
that these reform programs are the key
the absolute key
to restoring financial stability for the
first time ever south korea closed five
banks in a major step toward meeting its
imf mandate
the number of commercial banks has
declined has been reduced as a result of
closure
measures and
acquisitions and the
foreign strategic investors are now in
which which is a remarkable change
in asia government organized bailouts to
keep ailing financial institutions alive
were not allowed
but when a similar crisis struck back
home in america a year later
the very same institutions
reacted differently
the connecticut-based hedge fund
long-term capital management which
accepted as clients only high net worth
individual investors and institutions
had leveraged its five billion dollars
in client capital by more than 25 times
borrowing more than 100 billion us
dollars from the world's banks
when its losses threatened to undermine
the banks that had lent to it
with the possibility of a systemic
banking crisis that would endanger the
u.s financial system and economy
the federal reserve organized a
cartel-like bailout
by leaning on wall street and
international banks to contribute funds
so that it could avoid default
yeah and you're right the the views from
washington and new york seemed certainly
quite flexible because soon after they
told all the asian countries no bailouts
for financial institutions
when then long-term capital management a
hedge fund in new york almost went bust
suddenly a bailout was organized just
contradicting what they'd said to the
asian countries but the they say that
there are no public money used for ltcm
but the meeting was held famously inside
the federal reserve right
why would the united states make demands
on foreign nations in the name of the
free market
when it has no intention of enforcing
the same rules within its own borders
[Music]
the examples of the japanese and asian
crises illustrate how crises can be
engineered
to facilitate the redistribution of
economic ownership
and to implement legal structural and
political change
today similar events are at work in the
eurozone area
countries within the euro currency block
have forfeited their right to a national
currency and handed this power to the
european central bank
with me here in the studio is richard
verner he's professor at southampton
university richard was an adviser to the
bank of japan and the ministry of
finance at the end of the the bubble era
in the 1990s what's your advice to ecb
they meet tomorrow what would you be
what would you be telling them
um well again they have to focus on the
quantity of credit creation more than
interest rates the ecb has a lot um to
and to learn from its past mistakes
because basically i think it didn't
really watch carefully enough credit
creation where in spain um ireland
we had a massive credit expansion under
the watch of the ecb
he didn't look at that interest rates of
course the same in the euro zone
but the quantity of credit cycle is very
different there's one interest rate for
the whole euro area
but in 2002 the ecb told the bundesbank
to reduce its credit creation by the
biggest amount in its history
and told the irish central bank to to
print as much money as if there's no
tomorrow what do you expect is going to
happen same interest rate is the same
growth no
recession in germany boom in ireland
which one tells you that which variable
credit creation
from 2004 under the ecb's watch
bank credit growth in ireland greece
portugal and spain
increased by over 20 percent per annum
and property prices skyrocketed
when bank credit fell
property prices collapsed
developers went bankrupt
and the banking systems of ireland
portugal spain and greece became
insolvent
the ecb could have prevented these
bubbles
just as it could have ended the ensuing
banking and economic crises
but it refused to do so
until major political concessions had
been made
such as the transfer of fiscal and
budgeting powers from each sovereign
state to the european union
in both spain and greece
youth unemployment has been pushed up to
50 percent
forcing many youths to seek employment
abroad
greek doctors for whose education greek
taxpayers have paid
now work in germany
the deliberations of the ecb's
decision-making bodies are secret
the mere attempt at influencing the ecb
for instance through democratic debate
and discussion
is forbidden according to the maastricht
treaty
the ecb is an international organization
that is above and outside the laws and
jurisdictions of any individual nation
its senior staff carry diplomatic
passports
and the files and documents inside the
european central bank
cannot be searched or impounded by any
police force or public prosecutor
the ecb is well known among economists
as one of the world's most powerful and
least transparent central banks
yet its former president
jean-claude trishay
dealt with this problem by merely
asserting that there was no problem
the ecb
is one of the most transparent central
banks in the world
and has helped define the state of the
art of central banking in this domain he
claimed
the gentleman over there yes please my
name is richard vanna i'm an economist
my question is from mrtashe who's also
been for years member of the governing
council of the ecb the question is where
in the mastery treaty or ecb statutes
does it say that is the job of the ecb
to back structural reform or any other
political agenda i said very very
clearly and we have all said very very
clearly that we had no responsibility in
this domain
we have a voice and we say in this
domain and in some others what we think
and perhaps if we can help in explaining
from our side to the general people that
they would be better off perhaps it
would
help
europe
embarking in this implementation of
structural reforms which is so important
and there is a consensus on that the
diagnosis again
is
a very very very large consensus on this
on this point
the european commission
an unelected group whose aim is to build
the united states of europe with all the
trappings of a unified state
has an interest in weakening individual
governments and the influence of the
democratic parliaments of europe
[Music]
it turns out that the evidence for
central bank independence that was
relied upon in the maastricht treaty
derived from a single study that was
commissioned by none other than the
european commission itself
published in 1992 under the name
one market one money
the study purported to demonstrate that
central bank independence led to low
inflation
james forder an oxford academic
has since demonstrated that this study
was manipulated to obtain the desired
result
the story being told by the central
banks just does not add up
and there is evidence that central banks
work
differently from what they would like us
believe
as to how they work
the world over
central banks hold significant yet
little understood powers
often independent unaccountable and
obscure
central banks operate in the shadows
yet their actions affect us all
central banks
in almost all countries worldwide and
the imf has helped a lot in achieving
this they've become totally independent
and in practice not accountable to any
democratic institution
and accountability to parliament is
usually
minor and in practice meaningless
whether it is the bank of japan the
federal reserve
the bank of england or the european
central bank
examples of central bank deception
abound
in the united states in the 1920s
banks were encouraged to create money
and give it to speculators
[Music]
the resulting depression persuaded the
freedom-loving americans that a
decentralized federal system without
strong national controls could not work
[Music]
in the 1990s
the japanese were persuaded that their
economic system
which had brought considerable
prosperity and equality
needed to be changed into a so-called
free-market system
and while japan's transformation was not
yet complete
[Music]
the central bankers struck again
with an imf led raid on the asian tiger
economies
[Music]
the present european debt crisis
is yet another example of central bank
deception
to create a public consensus for the
need for structural reform
by purposefully creating a recession
and then needlessly prolonging it
must constitute an abuse of power
[Music]
do citizens really want to be
manipulated in such a costly and
dishonest manner
okay
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you